you'll learn to Vega on the podcast
would be a great get we want to get
Yolanda Vega on this podcast we'd like
to maybe she could even do this with her
if your family with her we'd love to get
Yolanda on this and if you don't know
her since I'm a young person uh this is
the woman who draws the New York State
lottery numbers thanks to my husband
Miguel I am hey babe
we got it my children are are Puerto
Rican so so you know as Puerto Ricans
um we only there's only two people who I
want my daughters to be either Yolanda
Vega or Fat Joe that's and and those are
you are the two king and queen Puerto
New York Puerto Rican so it's an honor
final number is 62. wow literally you
just enacted Sal's fantasy of Yolanda
Vega pulling Lottery balls out of his
lap
hahaha